continuemos con nuestro estudio
alrededor de los factores de producción
de una empresa y vamos a enfocarnos en
el mercado del trabajo y hemos dibujado
ejes así varias veces en el eje
horizontal tenemos a la cantidad de
trabajo que contrata la empresa y en el
eje vertical el salario no olvidemos que
esto es para la economía de una empresa
y estamos pensando en qué cantidad de
trabajo es racional contratar para la
empresa también hablamos varias veces
del ingreso marginal producto
este es el panorama de cuánto ingreso
adicional puede obtener la empresa cada
vez que incrementa las unidades de
trabajo y como ya hemos dicho
típicamente podemos ver una recta con
pendiente decreciente de esta forma ya
que tenemos rendimientos decrecientes
cada vez que tú agregas una unidad más
de trabajo el ingreso marginal producto
de ese trabajo disminuye un poco es por
eso que tenemos rendimientos
decrecientes así que aquí tenemos el
ingreso marginal producto y como
queremos ser muy específicos esta vez le
pondré la tf porque es el ingreso
marginal producto del trabajo y podemos
hacer algo similar para el ingreso
marginal producto de otros factores como
la tierra o el capital ahora para
cambiar un poco las cosas en este vídeo
no sólo hablaremos de una empresa que
opera en un mercado del trabajo en
competencia perfecta
si lo hiciéramos entonces su costo
marginal factor sería el salario
impuesto por el mercado y por lo tanto
sería una recta horizontal como ésta
este es nuestro costo marginal factor
del trabajo
como no hablaremos de una empresa que
opera en un mercado del trabajo en
competencia perfecta entonces hablaremos
de una empresa que es un monopolio una
palabra bastante elegante cuidado no es
un monopolio es un monopolio ahora que
significa monopsonio bueno lo puedes ver
como lo contrario a un monopolio en un
monopolio tienes un solo vendedor y
varios compradores déjame escribirlo un
vendedor y varios compradores esto es un
monopolio mientras que en un monopsonio
tienes un comprador y varios vendedores
déjame escribirlo un comprador y varios
vendedores esta es una empresa
monopolista déjame escribirlo un
comprador varios vendedores estamos
hablando de un monopolio el contexto del
que hablamos es el mercado de trabajo
así que vamos a decir que tenemos un
comprador de trabajo es decir un
empleador mientras que los vendedores de
trabajo son potenciales trabajadores
existen varios ejemplos en el mundo real
que se aproximan a empleadores con
opción istas digamos que estamos en una
pequeña ciudad y sólo hay un hospital
entonces ellos serán los empleadores
mano opción istas de los doctores y
enfermeras una cosa interesante de los
empleadores mano opción istas es que no
tomarán en cuenta el salario del mercado
ellos tienen esencialmente una curva de
oferta para el trabajo en ese mercado
así que por ejemplo en este mercado
cuando los salarios son bajos habrá una
oferta pequeña de trabajo no habrá
muchas personas que han trabajado en ese
hospital y mientras los salarios se
aumenten más personas querrán trabajar
para ese empleador monopolista así que
esta es nuestra curva de oferta de
trabajo
ahora bien te tengo una pregunta
capciosa cuál es la cantidad racional a
contratar para esta empresa
bueno seguramente estarás tentado a
decir es lo mismo vamos a seguir
contratando siempre que tu ingreso
marginal producto del trabajo sea mayor
que el costo de las unidades de trabajo
y esto sería cierto si te pudieras
permitir pagar a cada uno un salario
distinto si a esta primera unidad de
trabajo le pagas este salario y después
a cada uno que contrates le pagas un
poco más eso sería cierto pero esta no
es la forma típica en la que funciona en
el mundo real a menudo piensas en tener
que sea cual sea el salario si decidimos
que esta es la cantidad de trabajo que
contrataremos entonces no le pagaras ese
salario sólo a la persona adicional ya
que lo que realmente sucede es que le
pagaras ese salario a todos así que para
pensar en cuál es la cantidad racional
de trabajo que contrate la empresa
necesitamos calcular o al menos
considerar
es el costo marginal factor del trabajo
justo aquí que será diferente a la curva
de oferta para el trabajo y para
ayudarnos a considerar esto déjame
dibujar una pequeña tabla por aquí
déjame poner algunos números vamos a
pensar en la cantidad de trabajo y
tenemos 0 1 2 3 4 después pensemos en el
precio del trabajo vamos a decir que es
la cantidad de trabajo es 1 el precio
del trabajo es 3 y este precio aumenta
si queremos contratar más personas
aumenta a 456 y sigue ahora cuál será el
costo total del trabajo bueno lo podemos
calcular si tú contratas una unidad por
3 pesos bueno 1 por 3 es 32 unidades por
4 pesos por unidad
tenemos que pagar el mismo salario a
todos no es posible que a esta persona
le pagues tres pesos y sólo la segunda
persona le pagues cuatro pesos que en
este caso nos daría un total de siete
pesos pero si vas a contratar a dos
unidades entonces tienes que pagar a
cada una cuatro pesos así que tu total
es de ocho pesos dos por cuatro es ocho
pesos tres por cinco nos da un costo
total de 15 pesos y nuestro costo total
acá es de 24 pesos por lo tanto ahora
podemos calcular nuestro costo marginal
factor del trabajo es decir por cada
unidad de trabajo que aumentemos cuál es
el costo adicional que tenemos
bueno cuando vamos de 1 a 2 unidades
nuestro costo total aumenta de 3 a 8 por
lo que nuestro costo marginal factor es
5 aquí estamos sumando 5 cuando vamos de
2 a 3 nuestro costo marginal factor es
de 8 a 15 aquí
sumamos 7 entonces nuestro costo
marginal factor es de 7 una vez más esto
sucede porque cuando quieres contratar a
más personas
necesitarás pagar más para rastrear a
esas personas adicionales y entonces
tienes que pagarles el salario más alto
a todos así que puedes ver que el costo
marginal factor del trabajo va
aumentando el doble de rápido de lo que
aumenta la curva de oferta para el
trabajo en nuestra curva de oferta para
el trabajo por cada unidad adicional
estamos sumando 1 mientras que por aquí
por cada unidad adicional estamos
sumando 2 y podemos verlo de nuevo de 15
a 24 sumamos 9
por lo tanto nuestro costo marginal
factor es 9 podemos ver en este ejemplo
que nuestro costo marginal factor del
trabajo va a ir al doble de la pendiente
que nuestra curva de oferta para el
trabajo entonces nuestro costo marginal
factor del trabajo se va a ver algo así
va el doble de rápido déjame escribir
esta es la curva del costo marginal
factor del trabajo ahora tal vez en este
momento algo te indique que esto se
parece a algo que estudiamos en el
pasado cuando estudiamos monopolios o
una empresa en competencia imperfecta
hablamos sobre la demanda de sus bienes
y hablamos de su ingreso marginal y de
que la curva del ingreso marginal tenía
el doble que la pendiente negativa de la
curva de la demanda aquí podemos ver que
las cosas se han volteado porque no
estamos hablando ni del ingreso y del
ingreso marginal de la empresa estamos
hablando de los
de la empresa estos son los insumos de
la empresa ahora cuál será el salario
racional y cuál será la cantidad de
trabajo racional para la empresa bueno
ahora que ya hicimos el análisis
marginal lo que podemos ver como
racional para la empresa es seguir
contratando más y más personas siempre
que el ingreso marginal producto del
trabajo para cada unidad adicional de
trabajo sea mayor que el costo marginal
factor del trabajo para esa unidad
adicional así que nos mantenemos
contratando hasta que llegamos a este
punto de aquí y por lo tanto es racional
para la empresa contratar esta cantidad
de trabajo pero recuerda no tienes que
pagar este salario para esta cantidad de
trabajo la curva de oferta para el
trabajo nos dice que el salario de
mercado estará justo aquí así que
estaremos pagando este salario
así que tal vez esto para ti sea algo
para reflexionar un poco más pero el
resumen de todo esto es que si
trabajamos con una empresa mohn opción
ista o algo que se aproxima a ella
entonces solo hay una persona
contratando en el mercado y entonces
tiene su propia curva de oferta para el
trabajo y la forma en la que piensas
cuál es la cantidad de trabajo racional
para contratar es pensar sobre el costo
marginal factor del trabajo cuya
pendiente irá al doble de rápido y el
punto donde se interese que con el
ingreso marginal producto nos dirá la
cantidad mientras que la curva de oferta
para el trabajo nos dirá el salario para
esa cantidad de trabajo